foreign
let's go to Chicago and talk to Megan
what's up Megan
yes hi how are you Dr D I'm good what's
up dude how are you
of course
we just wanted to like give a little
shout out and say thank you for all you
do because you've really helped improve
our lives and also I think he's a little
jealous that I get to talk to you today
are you guys coming to the live event
Chicago
we are so we're very excited about that
all right I want you to hang on the line
and I'm gonna get your info from Jenna
and I'm Gonna Get You backstage and you
can come meet everybody and get photos
and and all that kind of stuff is that
cool
that is more than Beyond cool oh my gosh
my my husband's gonna be so excited okay
but you got to tell your husband that
like yeah like I know some folks and so
I hooked us up okay cool oh I will I'll
say it was my friends over at Ramsay's
Network even better if you don't tell
him at all and you ask him to wear the
literally the dumbest shirt he has in
his closet and then surprise him they'll
be captured in photo photo photo forever
right okay so all right under the call
so what's up
um so I guess I'll ask my question and
then give a little bit of context
um so now that I'm newly a mom uh how do
I stop my chronic people pleasing and
set up boundaries for my daughter my
family
well do seven somersaults and some jumpy
Jacks and it goes away I'm just kidding
so what give me a scenario you called
for a reason what happened
um so I have like kind of two scenarios
one that's recently happened and then
one we're trying to figure out how to
newly approach since the one didn't go
as how we were hoping
um our daughter was born extremely
premature at 26 weeks and for the safety
of her we set some rules uh when she
finally came out of the NICU but now
we've recently been kind of like guilt
tripped into trying to break those
boundaries okay hold on I'm gonna
interrupt you as we go is that cool yeah
oh sure I'm gonna teach you how to do
this for yourself as a people pleaser
okay
so one of the most important things is
to not let the ball get pushed off the
top of the mountain because the stone
because it just starts rolling and it
collects things remember those old
cartoons where the uh the snowball gets
pushed off the top of the mountain and
by the time you get to the bottom it's
just huge
that's what our thoughts do okay so I'm
gonna interrupt you and this is what you
need to do as you're heading into the
rest of of motherhood okay
number one
this child is your baby you and your
husband's baby
you made some rules as a couple about
the health and safety of your baby
probably in consultation with a doctor
nobody else gets a vote
okay
yes cool all right so when you were
walking on the street you're like I know
but they're starting to Guilt Trip
I'm gonna interrupt myself and go hold
on I'm the mom I'm the Mom nobody gets a
vote
except for my husband that's it
all right on to the next okay so they're
guilt tripping you
yeah I mean they've always just guilt
trip to us
um all four sets of families so sweet
yeah uh well because my parents are
divorced and then his parents are
currently working through their divorce
oh fantastic we have yeah so we have
four sets of families
um and she's the first grand baby
um so I'm trying to break like being a
people pleaser and learn how to set
boundaries because I want to lead by
example just knowing like I don't want
my daughter to grow up the same and
struggle with things and situations I
have because I was kind of raised this
way
um
okay let me let me interrupt so here's
at the core of people pleasing
what I think what I know and what I feel
matter less
than what everybody else thinks feels
and knows
and so the reversal of that process
is to begin with what kind of Life do I
want to live
what kind of home do me and my husband
want to co-create together
right and you you build that out that
way and often The Sounds
counterintuitive and it's very
non-instagramy right
start with feelings
what what do you want your home to feel
like when you all walk into it
I want my house I'll take me and my wife
do this exercise I wanted my house to
feel warm when I walked into it
and interestingly that meant I had to
clean up my crap
and when my house feels chaotic and a
little bit cold
it's often because I've got piles of
just stuff everywhere I'm a piler right
I wanted there to be laughter and joy in
my house
more so than frustration and bickering
and chaos
last night we put all the phones away
and we played trivia Pursuit and we have
the kid one for when my daughter gets
there and my son's with the adult one we
were talking trash we were laughing
dancing it was a just turned into a mess
and it ended with crying in tears like
they usually do but the 80 we got out it
was awesome right so but we chose I want
our house to feel like this and then we
reverse engineered that with what do we
have to do to make it that make it feel
like that right and and conversely what
do we want our holidays to feel like
what do we want the first three months
of our baby's life to feel like
and what do we need what has to be true
for that to to
um happen and it might be we don't visit
we're not visiting family for the first
90 days it's our first baby we're gonna
get our head screwed up on straight this
baby was really dicey out of the gate
we're gonna make sure everybody's on top
of things and then we'll reach back out
and that's you ending people pleasing by
saying I matter
the way I feel what I know to be true
what my doctor suggests what I think
that stuff matters
and that's how you work your way out of
it
and you're like that's cute okay but how
do I make them not hate me right
well uh so she's been home for about two
months so we did kind of go through
similarly that but funny enough my
question was about my face
how we approach that because uh we'd
want to kind of change family traditions
and start our own here which is
something that include shopping
Christmas morning alone say that out
loud probably in an email
okay okay
say that in email
me and a pretend your husband's name was
Dan me and Dan are creating our new
family traditions for our CORE family
unit and part of that will be we don't
travel on New Year's Day
part of that would be we don't travel on
Christmas Eve we wake up and have
Christmas as a family unit on Christmas
morning
and then you all decide what comes after
that if he has to go back to work the
next day that means we have from noon
until 7 pm at night before baby goes
down
and I want to tell you this this is hard
in divorced families and this is
unpopular what I'm about to say and I
don't care
they chose to get divorced
they chose
they decided as adults to either be able
to or not be able to be in the same room
together
they made that choice as adults they're
not babies they're not kids
and so if they have chosen to get
divorced and they have chosen to not be
able to I'm not be in the same room with
them or it'd be too weird great we're
making one stop
so we'll see y'all this year and we'll
see them next year
ta-da that is not y'all withholding that
is them making adult choices
you see the difference
yes and you Megan are not responsible
for other adult choices you're
responsible for you and your family unit
and you and your husband working
together
right yeah I know that's hard but listen
sending an email is good because a that
keeps the pressure people from talking
you out of what you've already decided
that stops the okay but oh all right
I'll call you back let me let me think
on it
um but but your dad has to do this thing
and your stepmom needs to go do this
with her kids and so we need you to be
here that's not gonna work this year
and so if you send out a map
via email
this is the way this is gonna be
and let me be honest with you 100 you're
gonna put up these boundaries as soon as
you told everybody you were pregnant
they created a picture in their mind of
what this baby was gonna do for their
life
any boundary you put up
is something they're gonna have to
grieve because it's changing the picture
that they created
but your baby is not a puzzle piece in
their puzzle
there this baby is not a pacifier for
their life
this baby is not a uh a cigarette or a
drink to make them feel better about the
world they've created
this is a human being and it's yours
and so I say that to say expect them to
be upset with you expect them to be like
well I just can't believe that I that's
fair that's fair
and I'm gonna tell you on the back end
of that years years later
my in-laws my parents are
are so respectful when we say hey this
year has been bananas this year we're
gonna have way more time this year we
can spend two days this year we can
spend one day or we're not traveling at
all that's the email we sent out last
year hey we're not we're not going to be
on the road this year
um John's traveling like crazy meeting
with businesses and
um we're just not going to travel we're
going to spend a time together as a
family and we're also not hosting this
year we're just gonna take a year off
I know that I know that was hard for my
parents I know that
and they were so respectful because we
built a culture of they trust the Sun
that they raised my wife's parents trust
the the daughter that they raised that
they're going to do what's best for
their family unit
see what I'm saying
yes yes yeah uh the mama bear me really
wants to do this I guess it just hurts
when I get called neurotic for doing so
listen listen they're gonna call you way
worse before it's over
and can I be honest with you you
probably are a little neurotic and
that's okay
you know right probably you are a little
bit right yeah okay so it's fair it's
fair what I think is really important in
these moments um honestly is a couple of
girlfriends of yours that you have 24
hour 365 text availability
uh I remember watching my wife she was
smart enough to get that on the front
end and it was a it was a lifeline
because she was able to text a group of
three women I think it was maybe four
24 7 365. hey is this rash normal is
this weird
what happens if there's fever like I
feel like I hate my husband is this all
normal and they had she had friends that
would respond instantly
and
um there is uh I'll push back on culture
a little bit here too there is part of
of a family Legacy you have to make the
trip sometimes right you got to go see
family it's it's long it's annoying
um being a part of a family tree does
not mean it's always just the greatest
thing ever there is long road trips for
a one day trip there is expensive flight
sometimes that's part of it
and so I don't want you to create
boundaries so much that you isolate
yourself from everybody
um
but you get to decide when those long
trips are going to be and for what
purposes and having a group of women in
your life that you can text and be like
am I crazy am I neurotic and they'll go
yeah you're insane go to the birthday
what's the matter with you
um and they don't have any they don't
have any skin in the game other than
they love you and they'll tell you the
truth
is that fair
yeah
it keeps you from feeling like you are
fighting in-laws by yourself
and having to decide why all four of
these adults couples
um are ganging up on you all right
right
um here's the here's the exercise I want
you to do I want you to get your husband
and I want you all to start with how do
we want the first holiday with our new
baby to feel
we want to feel adventurous to want to
feel still and quiet and calm so we want
to feel gentle do we want to feel like a
party you get to decide everybody's
different
and then you get to decide from there
okay that means we probably shouldn't
travel this year if we want to be calm
and chill we should not travel we want
to have Adventures we want our first our
first uh Christmas with our little one
we have to be like fun and like we're
cool parents still
great get a two-week road trip take off
work go get them right you all get to
decide that but I want you all to begin
to map it out and as you enter into
September October send the email out
early
to All Families
this is what this is going to be and by
the way if they're like we don't like to
be included on emails with your your
mother's ex-hus sorry I'm sending one
email guys I'm not gonna
I'm not going to cut the crust off your
bread you could be an adult
um but I'm going to send this out to
everybody and just say hey look
um
here's what we're gonna do for Christmas
this year here's when we're going to be
available or not available
and um
we're so honored that you're going to
walk alongside us as we create this new
family and I think just taking some
ownership there let them say what
they're gonna say and by the way if they
say a bunch of ugly mean stuff then
um they may opt out completely
to decide that you get to decide that
stay on the line um Jen is gonna she's
gonna get your info for the backstage
stuff and um she's gonna send you a copy
of my brand new book building a
non-anxious life I want you and your
husband to work through this book
together and exercise as You Follow the
path
I think it would help your home your
entire home to say okay
who are we attached to that's running
our life force who are we trying to
please what companies are telling us
what we're doing with our time and our
money and whatever
it's going to help you reclaim ownership
it's a book about empowerment and hope
and I want to give that to you all as a
gift as your uh as a baby gift
um for y'all to create a home that's
going to be different than the one you
grew up in and a marriage is going to be
different than the one you all both
watched Fall Apart
a kid that's not gonna be a people
pleaser but a kid that's going to know
their own inherent value and worth